Hi, my name is Jay and
I'm the course developer of
the Advanced Android Development and
Google services classes.
I'm here to introduce
you to Project Zero.
Project Zero is the first
project of your nanodegree.
And while it's not required for
graduation, it's a really good way to
get started building apps right away.
This project will be a central hub
from which you can launch the other
apps you'll be building.
For now, each of these buttons will
just display a little message that says
something like, this button will
launch my media streamer app.
As soon as you learn
about direct intents and
developing Android apps, you'll be able
to launch the other apps you'll build as
part of your Nanodegree
from these buttons.
Whenever you finish another project,
you can come here to update this hub,
keeping your whole Nanodegree
portfolio within easy reach.
To make this app you'll need to
complete five steps laid out in
detail in the next node.
You'll install Android Studio, create
new project, customize your layout,
tie each button to code, and
launch a message from each button.
With that,
you'll have built your very first app.
Welcome again, to the Android
Developer Nanodegree, and good luck.